[Music]
now on to the cop 26 climates change
summit in glasgow it's now halfway
through but are we really getting a
debate
this week's issue has got an article by
nigel lawson a former chancellor and of
course this magazine's former editor
where he says that a lot of this
discussion on a false premise he's not
convinced that there is a great um
tragedy about to unfold and he was
saying the solutions being proposed will
make things worse not better well we
also have a piece from gavin schmitz
who's a climate change scientist at nasa
he argues that things are every bit as
bad as people say he joins me now as
does benny pfizer from the global
warming policy foundation which nigel
lawson helped to set up now gavin
schmitz let's start with you first isn't
it simply the case that the renewable
energy revolution we're hoping for isn't
going to come along in time to hit the
next zero target and us as such the
conversation we're having isn't quite in
tune with reality unless we're talking
about nuclear power which from what i
gather is banned from even exhibiting at
the cop26 summit then we're really not
going to get to the whole picture that
would allow britain to transition
properly away from fossil fuels well
let's take a little bit of a step back
why are we doing all of this right we
have seen over a degree change in uh
global temperatures we're seeing that
having impacts directly in heat waves
and intense rainfall and in storms and
in sea level rise and in coastal
flooding and in intense precipitation we
are seeing the impacts right now of the
climate changes we've already had we
know what's causing them we know that
it's being driven mainly by our
emissions of greenhouse gases
particularly carbon dioxide and we can
predict what's going to happen into the
future now those damages are going to
occur they're already occurring and if
we don't stop the emissions
those damages will increase and so now
we have a situation where we know that
certain activities uh that we indulge in
as a society are having harm and the
moral thing to do is to see if we can
mitigate that harm right and so the
discussions at glasgow the discussions
that are going on uh elsewhere around
the world uh related to this are all
about how fast can we stop doing that
harm
it's not that complicated now
how that happens how fast that happens
those are going to be very difficult
decisions because it depends on the
technology which for renewables has been
getting cheaper and cheaper and cheaper
it depends on how we
organize our societies what what rules
we mandate what uh what subsidies we
give what what taxes we impose all of
those things are going to affect uh how
much emissions go on into the future but
the key thing that comes from the
science
is the realization that all of the
future warming and the future impacts
are actually related to our future
emissions and so any reduction in
emissions that we have going forward
uh is going to reduce damages into the
future and so every little bit counts
and so whether we can uh
uh you know have an argument well you
know is this conceivable by 2050 or by
2060 or by 2017 none of those things
really matter too much as long as we're
on the trajectory that is reducing those
emissions and that's the only way that
we're going to reduce those harms but
the question to cop 26 is whether um
countries can sign up to a net zero
pledge by 2050. now britain's one of
them well that's not that's not quite
right so so cop 26 is the opportunity
after five years after the paris accord
uh for countries to um upgrade their
independently determined uh
contributions to those reductions
and different countries are
independently coming up with ideas about
what they think that they can do right
nobody is imposing that upon them they
are independently saying we think that
we can do this now i don't wanna i'm not
gonna say that the uk can't do what it's
saying or that china can't do what it's
saying
i have to trust that they know what
they're talking about because i can't go
in and check everything for them right
but
what's going on is that they're becoming
more ambitious and uh by setting goals
like net zero carbon dioxide by 2050 uh
their singling um and putting into place
by law in the uk are mechanisms and ways
to get there so bendy fires the
renewables are becoming cheaper all the
time therefore i put you but it's quite
credible that things will develop in the
way the british government says they
will
yeah i was a bit cynical um
let's face it what we've heard for the
last 10 minutes is the kind of
mantra we've heard for the last 30 years
what's the problem with it what was
gavin schmitz said which is incorrect
well
nothing that western governments have
done
in throwing
trillions at renewables have
halted the rise of co2 co2 is rising
steadily
and if renewables were as cheap as gavin
claims most governments would adopt them
the reason why
we have the problem at cop 26 is that
china india and the rest of the
developing world can realize just how
bad the situation is in britain and in
europe with energy prices going through
the roof and renewables causing all
sorts of unintended consequences
like yesterday where consumers had to
pay 50 million to keep the lights on
so
as i said if renewables are so cheap as
we've been told over and over again
there wouldn't be a problem the problem
is
governments don't take this seriously
otherwise we wouldn't have the problem
we have right
now realistically
co2 emissions will continue to rise for
the next 10 years they're not going to
go down
and governments around the world are not
adopting
radical decarbonization policies and
that's the real that's the reality
but let's look at the reality in britain
then britain is a country where we
decarbonize faster than any other g20
country over the last 10 years no matter
how much you measure it our co2
emissions are now back down to levels
not seen since the victorian days
renewables the strike price of wind
power is coming down all the time in a
way far lower than people thought it
would be 10 years ago and sure china
isn't following suit the world isn't
following suit but if you look at the
model that britain has adopted isn't
that a model where renewables take an
ever greater part of the strain and
that's a model that china or india could
one day adopt when they get rich enough
and all of a sudden we can see a path
for the world to hit net zero and for
global warming temperatures to be
restricted to 1.5
yeah it's a it's it's a great story
unfortunately no one around the world is
actually buying into it otherwise they
would adopt the british model what they
are seeing is
britain struggling at europe struggling
with an extreme energy crisis energy
prices going through the roof and we're
facing
real problems with stabilizing the
national grid as i said yesterday 50
million just to keep the lights on so um
as i said if this if britain were such a
trailblazer many countries would adopt
similar policies the reason that most
developing and emerging nations don't
and are refusing to adopt these policies
is they can see that they're not working
they're not working at all and most of
our
manufacturing
high energy industries have already
moved abroad because you can't afford to
invest in britain if you use a lot of
energy it's far too expensive in europe
basically those industries have to be
subsidized left right and center so
the reality is there is a deep divide
international divide there's no way out
and
most of the developing world for the
next 10 20 30 years will use
cheap abundant available fossil fuels
right that's the and all energy agencies
are actually predicting that by 2050
still half of the global energy mix will
be based on fossil fuels now gavin
schmidt that's a
fair point isn't this because we all
know that
whatever europeans may emit in britain
is responsible for one percent of carbon
emissions so sure we might hit net zero
but that i don't i put to you would that
even move the dial on the global warring
problem if we did that and if it
wouldn't then we are looking at india
and china now and and china gets the
majority of its energy now from coal
burning fuel plants and as a country
it's still got gdp per capita like a
quarter of that of britain they've got a
lot of poverty to eliminate india's got
150 million people in extreme poverty so
they are not really going to go at a
particularly fast pace because they need
to get their people out of the hunger
line now once they do that they might
get to livestream so the interesting
thing about uh climate policy is they
intersect with all sorts of other
policies as well um one of the other
main issues that the that is plaguing uh
both china and india is the problem of
air pollution uh air pollution mainly
from the burning of fossil fuels uh is
causing hundreds of thousands of
premature deaths in these countries uh
they have an absolute urgent need uh to
move away from polluting
energy sources
and they are doing so um one of the
things
that they're doing um in in india uh you
know they have open auctions for
new power supplies those auctions are
being won by soda
uh um plans not by new coal plants this
this notion that uh that that coal is
cheap uh
and therefore everyone is using it it's
not cheap because they're having to pay
the costs of the associated air
pollution uh the uh the the the the
deaths from uh from coal mining uh the
appalling conditions of the miners uh
fossil fuels are not uh uh this this
wonderful panacea that is going to bring
everybody out of poverty because if it
were uh they would have done it a
hundred years ago why did that because
of the technology
china's made incredible progress out of
poverty over the last 20 years it's gone
from sixty percent to one
fossil fuels are nowhere near it you've
got something like a million children in
your diarrhea every year you have
something like three million cases of um
tuberculosis these are things that are
linked to india's poverty and when
countries rise to their agrarian knees
they do so by living a bit more like we
do in the west and that means fossil
fuel
right so but but but the developing
countries are not just adopting what we
did with the same history they are able
to leapfrog a lot of the things that we
did like there is there is never going
to be a comprehensive landline telephone
industry in india or china because they
leaped ahead of that and now they have
cell phones we can help them and they
will help us uh by helping uh to both
develop and
uh and uh and manufacture uh the
technology that will allow them to get
ahead of the problems that we've had
associated with fossil fuels
this is not this is not a
this is not an easy task um and it's
clear that uh energy needs in in india
and other developing nations uh are are
very are very real um but we can be
helping them and they can help us by
doing uh
most of that with renewables right now
but benefit we've had china promised to
hit net zero by 2060. that's a pretty
big promise we've had india promise to
do it by 2070 again that's not to be
sneezed at so i put to you that the cop
26 is actually producing some tangible
program process and it's doing on a time
scale we're sure we measure in decades
but we measure our own pressure admit
progress in decades what matters surely
is that the world's countries are now
beginning to get agree to the
decarbonisation agenda which um gavin
schmidt has just set out
fraser look let's be real here
um china and india are making these kind
of conditional pledges you know these
pledges are conditional on trillions of
dollars
having to be
transferred from
the u.s and europe to the developing
world it's conditional these are not
kind of pledges we're doing this no they
are only doing this if the money flows
in their direction and can i just say
let's forget for a moment india and
china and asia and africa and the rest
of the developing world let's forget all
of this and look at the us
president biden came to cop and made
some pledges no one believes a word he
makes he says no one believes that he's
trustworthy or credible he can't even
get his pledge through his own party
never mind through the senate
the us is never going to give up on its
huge treasure of fossil fuels believe
you me there's no chance
that the us will give up on oil gas and
coal for the next 30 years
simple
what i'm hearing from you benny is just
excuses for why nobody should do
anything you already know
that's not the way that's not the truth
what i'm saying is
the problem the west and the greens and
the climate activists
have is they've
basically made a huge mistake by
believing that you can solve the problem
of co2 emissions with renewables
the problem is that the world is looking
at the countries with high level of
renewables and they're seeing all sorts
of problems whether it's rising energy
prices whether it's in stable national
grids whether it's blackouts if
if and that's a big if these kind of
claims with you know it's one minute
before doomsday we're facing extinction
and so if that were true governments
would take policies where you can
actually produce energy reliably and
cost effectively and take the public
with you
give up renewables go for nuclear go for
low carbon natural gas and then you can
decarbonize you cannot decarbonize the
economy with renewables that is what the
world is realizing today
gavin schmitz and benny pfizer thanks
very much indeed
[Music]
you